ambiance bon enfant au départ du cortège
une foule dense pas rapidement occuper
la rue pour certains la manifestation
est un rendez vous de plus pour d'autres
c'est la première fois
jusqu'à présent c'était un peu ciblées
c'était possible et sur les taxes et
tout mais je trouve que c'est l'occasion
justement de de faire part du gros
ras-le-bol quoi c'est plus possible
c'est une asphyxie à tous les niveaux il
ya des gens de toutes catégories au
temps des retraités que des étudiants et
tout on est tous là dans le même but
c'est que notre pouvoir d'achat notre
vie soit meilleur c'est au pont depuis
le 17 novembre la mobilisation demeure
bien présente les manifestants ne
trouvent pas leur compte dans les
propositions du gouvernement
les revendications sont toujours là
après elles sont divers et variés il
faut rencontrer chaque gilet jaune pour
avoir leur point de vue on a
l'impression que le gouvernement se
fiche de nous en fait voilà après on
n'est pas là pour casser on n'est pas là
on est juste là pour montrer qu'en fait
on n'est pas content c'est tout bien que
les gilet jaune désapprouvent les actes
de violence les débordements qui ont pu
se produire sont selon eux l'expression
d'une exaspération générale
malheureusement il faut qu'eads la
violence pourquoi
réagissent si ça se passait
pacifiquement tout le monde s'en fichait
c'est dommage après un grand tour de
ville le cortège est revenu rue de la
préfecture et place de la république
des tensions ont commencé avec les
forces de l'ordre puis des affrontements
grenades lacrymogènes contre feux
d'artifice du mobilier urbain a été
incendié des manifestants nous ont
signalé cinq à dix blessés légers
lors de la dispersion